do you like cats well this video is
sponsored by battle cats
a free-to-play tower defense game where
you get to send an army of cats to do
battle one cats we got all of the cats
getting KITT that's not even a cat she's
a [ __ ] has a name EQ character you
got sumo cats you got a samurai cats you
got sardick Oh cat and then you got
tights cat who thought of this
abomination you've got to use the cast
to your disposal to talk with the
various stages as they just progressed
it can get pretty challenging so careful
for needs to be put into your formation
or cast to use whether your team comp
it's balanced and most importantly how
many anime characters can you fit in
cats can range from different strengths
and rarities and the variety here is
absolutely insane I even managed to get
myself a Jojo cats a freaking Jojo cat
ticket Locker
chicas Guernica turner boots enormous
enemy starting May 1st they are also
celebrating their 50 millionth download
and offering tons of free in game
rewards limited edition stages and the
super fest capsule set there has a high
chance of collecting top tier uber cats
so if you want to dive into the world of
battlecast today click the link in the
description to download it on iOS or
Android and with that said let's get on
with the video we all have our origin
stories about how we came to discover
anime and find out we love these
animations that came from Japan but I'm
sure for many of you anime isn't the
only medium you've become a fan of and
might not even be the only foreign
medium you've come to love for me some
of my fondest childhood memories growing
up was whenever I'd go to my cousin's
house and he put on different martial
arts films that we would end up spending
all nights watching Bruce Lee Jackie
Chan Jet Li I grew up in a lot of these
og Hong Kong martial arts flicks and
this love remains as we grew older where
he would continue to show me films like
Kung Fu Hustle on bark the raid Yip Man
Killzone SPL so of course when I became
the anime and manga fan that I did my
natural instincts was to see if there
were any titles that were reminiscent to
these types of movies and through this
search I discovered two series Veritas
and the breaker to this day these are
two of my favorite martial arts face
manga that I found know Tony was yot on
par or greater than the best of any
shounen jump action series you can find
but a damn near takes every box I was
looking for
from insane fights the perfect underdog
story and a setting focus on the
underground world of martial arts there
was surprisingly far less common than I
thought it would be in the world of
anime but there was something strange
about them while they looks like any
other manga I was reading from left to
right and these names didn't sound like
any of the Japanese names my weed miner
got so accustomed to and it was then
that I realized that these words manga
at all there were from Korea and they
were called Manoir and through that I
discovered that the Koreans have been
popularizing this entirely new formats
called web comics on this platform
called webtoons he was an entirely new
world of stories and comics that I would
have never discovered if I only cared
about what was coming out of Japan while
still feeling very reminiscent to the
stories found in anime some of which
were just as good but it was then that I
some believed realized that these
stories weren't from Japan and so there
would be zero chance I would ever get to
see any of them adapted into anime form
and given the chance to fully shine like
many of the Japanese manga I had come to
fall in love with or at least that's
what I thought until now
[Music]
Tower of God is airing this season and
it may well be the most important anime
to come out in years but it's not alone
this year it was announced that god of
high school and the police would both be
getting anime adaptations too and this
was massive news not least because all
three leads are korean web comics that
found international distribution through
webtoons to me this is news that could
spell a shift for the entire industry
itself but before we get into what these
shows could mean for animes a whole
what's all the hype around Tower of God
anyway this season Tower of God has not
only filled the heavy role of being one
of the only shows that hasn't been
indefinitely delayed but is also coming
in as a contender for the new hype shown
in action series and so far has done a
pretty damn good job the main premise
revolves around this almighty towel that
can apparently grant whatever wish or
desire or something to people who can
successfully climb it exactly what's at
the top of the tower is left kind of
vague as it's only really there to give
the characters some sort of motivation
to ascend as the story progresses the
ultimate goal of reaching the top of the
tower becomes less and less important
because what really shines about the
series is the worlds buildings the
fights and the characters the tower is
less of a structure more like an entire
world in and of itself each floor has
its own dynamics rules social structure
and sometimes even ecosystem we are
thrown headfirst into this massive world
where you're only ever shown one tiny
bit at a time
there's no hand-holding where a
character just immediately dumps the
entire history of everything you need to
know on your lap you are left to
discover the world with the protagonist
you hear bits about the history the
geography the political structure and
piece by piece this floody builds up
your understanding of the tower as a
whole and as the pieces start connecting
it evolves into this grand story you
really get a sense just by watching the
first few episodes that you're standing
at the base of this enormous mountain
and you're just seeing a tiny glimpse of
the entire thing and I love that feeling
the feeling that you're not just seeing
this generic world being made up as the
story progresses we are stepping into a
pre-existing one with centuries of
history and law that was constructed
before the story was even started as one
of those series where you watch two
episodes and he think yeah I could see
this being a 300 episode kind of deal
and I feel a similar level of thought
has been put into the power systems and
fights because it's intrinsically tied
to the mechanics of the world and what
really enables it to shine is the
various tests on every floor to ascend
participants have to pass various tests
which can range from simple
death battles for more laboratorians but
as we learn more about the power systems
the tactics behind passing a tests
becomes more intricate there are always
several layers behind every action taken
and this is especially true when it's
constricted behind the rules of whatever
test they are taking the action in the
anime might not be as flashy or well
animated as something like a UFO or
bones adaptation but I think the writing
behind it more than makes up for it and
I think that's the same reason why
despite the early art of the webcomic
being lackluster at times it still
manages to really engage you oh and you
know there's also this bloke called
Kevin thinking who did the soundtracks
and made in the bits and shield hero
who's doing the music here and I mean I
guess he's kind of doing a good job or
something I don't know I don't really
know the guy or anything am i mate or
friend I think you might be Australian
well this is a Korean webcomic you can
feel the influences of some of the best
shounen jump action series because you
get the same grand sense of world
building like you do from something like
one piece while the fights and tests are
structured way more reminiscent to
something like hunter hunter
I knew it had potential to stand up with
this shown in competitors when I
switched on an episode and after five
minutes the episode ends and then you
look at your clock and you like wait
what the [ __ ] do you mean that was
twenty minutes if there was a weak
points for me it lies with the main
character because he suffers from a
severe case of stupidly ignorant main
protagonist syndrome wait a minute BAM
suffers from being that generic naive
nice guy protagonist without the same
charm you've seen a lot of similar cases
a huge issue I had when trying to get
invested in the web comics was that he
was just so much more boring compared to
literally everyone around him because
without spoiling there are a lot of
interesting characters with various
compelling motivations to get good
development over the course of the story
and compared to that it was really hard
for me to invest in BAM as a character
and how the plot revolved around him
thankfully it does get better deeper in
the story but my god does it take a
while but you know what all this is fine
because we all know rock is the real
main character anyway all in oh I see
Tower of God being a welcome addition to
the shown in action genre but my biggest
worry is that this anime will barely
scratch the surface of the full story
this isn't a quick disposable one season
kind of story there are 400 plus
chapters for a reason and with the anime
only confirmed for 13 episodes it's
hardly gonna make a dent to put this in
perspective the webcomic is split into
seasons season 1 is around 70 chapters
and that's basically just the prologue
yes
prolog with 13 episodes either a lot of
things are going to be cut out or we can
have an anime that stops halfway through
the start of this tale for me it didn't
start to hit a stride until season 2 it
took me a week to slog through season 1
and then season 2 hits and I just
casually read a hundred chapters in a
day so take that as you will if it does
manage to reach some of its full
potential though do I think it's a
series that could pave the way for a new
era of webtoons anime absolutely
[Music]
well Tower of God and the upcoming god
of high school and the police represents
is an evolution for anime because it
doesn't seem like this could be a
one-time thing but a continuing
partnership between crunchyroll and
webtoons what this means is that
webtoons could be a new consistent
platform where we find material for
anime and i think that's a big step for
the medium to be clear there was already
one webtoons adaptation of knobblies but
that was limited to a one episode OVA
and nothing close to the fully
serialized adaptations we are getting
now and these weren't some no-name
in-house studio adapting them either
Tower of God was being done by telecom
animation film god of high school was
being hounded by Studio mapa and
production i.g was doing the police this
was massive when it comes to foreign
source material in anime it's not an
idea that's entirely alien but from what
I could finds these were limited to two
basic categories either it was something
from classic literature like The Count
of Monte Cristo Romeo and Juliet Alice
in Wonderland and anything from Lord
masterpiece theater or it was an
addition to an already established
pre-existing franchise like the Marvel
madhouse adaptations or a video game
tie-in like Halo or Mass Effect getting
an adaptation of an original story
outside of Japan is almost unheard of
the closest thing I see is Chinese
animation sometimes getting a Japanese
broadcast or series like freezing and
radiance which had authors from career
and France respectively but both at
least had physical publications in Japan
not only is webtoons an international
platform but compared to a medium like
manga web comics is a very very young
medium but has slowly been gaining
insane popularity over the past decade
tower of got itself garnered 4.5 billion
views worldwide before its anime started
airing and more something like this
shows is that there is a massive
audience for anime style content that
isn't necessarily from Japanese manga or
light novels or interest me about
webtoons as the platform is that it's a
medium that was
birth in the digital age a minutes one
that's specifically designed to be read
on smartphones and tablets with that one
long unending page they just vertically
scroll down so unlike manga actually
trying to read a webcomic on paper would
be like paper it's a platform that was
designed for the age of the Internet has
really embraced how modern content is
made and how we consume our media which
is why I think it has such a big
international appeal on launched in 2014
it was merely a platform for an
international audience to read
officially translated Korean web comics
but now has become a place for
user-generated content like YouTube
where anyone can publish their work on
the site and a big reason this excites
me is because this opens up so many
possibilities for stories from different
cultural backgrounds don't get me wrong
anime is already diverse as hell but
most of the stories unsurprisingly find
its roots from Japanese culture and this
can limit the types of stories and
settings that we see the entire reason I
found very tiresome the brakeman the
first place was because it was
surprisingly difficult to find good
martial arts based manga and anime you'd
think the crazy world of martial arts
combined with the shown in battle
formula it's pretty much a match made in
heaven but there's only really a handful
of titles to pick from so it was hard to
find exactly what I was looking for yet
it was exceedingly easy to find when it
came to Korean and Chinese comics
because there are so many what I'm
trying to say is part of the appeal I
found from getting into web comics mana
or dong-ha is that it still felt like I
was watching anime while being
refreshing enough to not fall into some
of the same cultural cliches we've
gotten so used to because hell they all
have their own cliches to be clear I
don't expect to webtoons to take over as
the primary source of source material
but like I we saw the rise of life's
novel adaptations in the mid 2000s
international web comics could become an
additional Avenue for anime adaptations
because the audience is there and it's
getting very very popular to me webtoons
isn't the perfect platform I think the
lack of an editorial backbone makes it a
lot harder to find good titles and the
best on there still can't compete with
the best of what we can find in manga
just yet but it's still a very young
platform and the fact that we are
getting webtoons adaptations opened so
many doors because this isn't just
limited to web teams either there are
plenty of other titles like solo
leveling which is another korean
webcomic outside of webtoons that is
getting insanely popular and if they
ever got an anime adaptation would
probably do pretty damn well what I want
to end this video on is not to
say you should hold out hope for a
breakout adaptation or that solo
leveling is just a matter of time but
that we've come to a point in anime
where the rules we once thought they
worked by are starting to bend Manoir
and Manoir are simply just the Korean
and Chinese terms for all comic-book
storytelling like manga is for Japanese
comic books but for us in the West they
are mainly what we refer to as very
Japanese inspired manga like comics from
those regions miss Swire lots of them
are visually indistinguishable for manga
and why certain Western companies in the
past like Tokyo pop have swords Korean
and Chinese comics as manga you could
even say that maybe the concept of anime
and manga itself is just becoming a
brand for us in the West but who the
[ __ ] would actually say that with the
addition of webtoons anime has opened up
a new avenue of source material to be
adapted and it's not based on any
culture or geological background but
simply stories that can gain an audience
Tower of God I feel is the first step
towards this and whether this is your
kind of show or you think this is just
another over-height shown in flavor of
the year you should have your eyes
peeled over the coming months over the
impact this show has along we've got of
high school when it starts next season
because if they take off which I very
much think they have the potential to do
so we could be witnessing the start of a
new era for anime
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much to battle cats for
sponsoring me today if any of what I
showed looked interesting to you then
click that link in the description to
try it today and with that said thank
you very much two sisters one zero zero
eight six job mondo Ella fall dazzle and
everyone else my patron bear helped me
to support me for this month you know
this is normally the point where I give
some new updates about what's going a
month in my life but what the [ __ ] is
there to say right I've been inside or
the events I've planned have been
canceled so um yeah I've got nothing so
you know what I'm just gonna leave her
that today to keep it short and sweet so
until my next video
I've been gig up and I'll see you all
next time